bonsoir à toutes et à tous
alors après avoir écouté les jeunes
démocrates on va faire comme dans les
émissions politiques on va débriefer le
débat
et du coup voilà du coup on vous invite
à rester parce que la salle se leclerc
se
se classe m
mais pour autant pour autant on a invité
trois
intervenantes a à faire écho à ce qui
vient d'être dit et donc d'abord
évidemment je voulais partager
l'enthousiasmé qui venait d'être
manifester en disant bravo bravo à
l'ensemble des débatteurs de la table
ronde parce que franchement vous êtes
prêté à un exercice qui est pas toujours
simple
mais vous l'avez fait vraiment avec
beaucoup de conviction avec beaucoup de
facilité et on vous en félicite alors
peut-être avant de laisser réagir nos
trois personnalités c est nommé sarah et
la hérie isabelle florennes et geneviève
darrieussecq je voulais reprendre
quelques points du débat et quelques
points de ce que chacun d'entre vous 5
aviez aviez échangé
ce que tout le monde est avec nous
voilà vous avez tout compris
alors d'abord moi j'ai retenu
de chacun d'entre vous alors je commence
par arnaud alors les noms ne sont plus
affichées là mais heureusement je les ai
noté je commence par arnaud qui parlait
de deux d'entre eux soient politiques de
technocrates élus et de crise du récit
j'ai trouvé intéressant son son voile à
sa manière d'aborder le sujet jeu par
rapport à ce que disait alexandre 1 à 2
chez l air elle a parlé de l est là
bravo donc et jeu par rapport à ce que
est ce qu'elle disait sur la question
des jeunes pros et de la manière dont il
se sentait pas écouté et pas pris en
considération je pense que c'est
effectivement un point qui doit tous
nous interpeller sur l'intervention de
lol nolwenn d'europe écologie les verts
j'ai le noter et qu'elle disait que les
jeunes ne se sentent pas avoir de la
valeur et ne se sentent pas entendus
j'espère qu'ici vous vous êtes senti
entendu parce qu'en tout cas c'était le
but et c'était l'esprit et vous disiez
vous vous parliez de des canaux
d'information vous avez mentionné
l'éducation morale et civique enfin non
vous avez plutôt l'éducation en général
mais du coup je pense que nos
intervenantes vont parler de l'éducation
morale et civique sur ce que disait
ambroise méjean qui est devant moi et
que je félicite alors l'appel de la
croix effectivement on est plusieurs ici
à l'avoir lu entendu signé et c'est
c'est effectivement une initiative
bienvenue alors ambroise vous avez
mentionné les étudiants et les jeunes
pros et je pense qu'il faut pas oublier
dans ce débat les jeunes déscolarisés
parce que ils sont quand même nombreux
et chaque année il ya des il ya des
dizaines de milliers de jeunes
déscolarisés il faut aussi que à un
moment on les prenne en compte dans la
question de du débat démocratique et
comment aussi peuvent trouver leur place
et vous avez parlé de l'importance de
structurer le débat politique notamment
c'était très clair dans les européennes
c'est ce que vous avez dit et d'ailleurs
d'autres ont dit c'est clair que les
programmes de départementales et
régionales on savait pas les caisses qui
différenciait les programmes de droite
et de gauche et c'était intéressant de
l'avoir souligné sur ce que disait
auguste évidemment la proportionnelle on
est tous d'accord là la question de la
pipolisation de la présidentielle
c'était intéressant ce point que tu
soulignait et je voulais te dire que tu
n'as pas à t'excuser de bousculer le
mouvement
et antonin pour terminer à mentionner un
débat pollué par des sujets qui
n'intéressait pas forcément les jeunes
et j'ai trouvé très intéressant le fait
que deux d'entre vous ai parlé de
raphaël glucksmann des ouigours et du
fait qu en fait voilà c'est d'aider des
sujets qui qui peuvent intéresser des
jeunes et donc peut-être on se saisit
pas spontanément alors mesdames vous
avez donc 20 minutes pour réagir à ce
que
est ce que les cinq les six jeunes
autour de la table ont
exprimé et peut-être à partager avec
avec nous vos propositions alors
peut-être fait commencer par qui par
part ça va sarah peut-être ta ta
réaction à ce qui vient d'être partagée
merci beaucoup et j'ai adoré ce moment
très sincèrement il ya des moments comme
ça où on se dit se passe quelque chose
et ce moment il avait la force de la
franchise
l'énergie de la conviction et de
l'action et en même temps on s'est dit
ce qui marchait pas dans nos partis est
ce qu'on a envie de développer et ce qui
convient c'est parti on a eu finalement
je crois que c'était lektroluv
démocratique au lendemain des régionales
tous et c'est nrj moi je les retrouver
dans une réunion également que j'ai que
j'avais embarqué une sorte de
consultation des mouvements jeunes juste
après les régionales et je vais rester
sur un point parce que beaucoup de
conclusions ont été faites très ce point
de propositions partagées la deuxième
les conclusions et la deuxième étape des
consultations arrivera le mois prochain
pour concrètement mettre des choses
parce que pour le coup autant auguste
qu'ambroise on dit l'efficacité l'action
et l'immédiateté telle action donc ça
donne aussi de la puissance à nos
engagements et donc moi je vais prendre
un point parce que en fait on va se
compléter et donc moi je vais à parler
que de la partie éducation pour rappeler
à quel point effectivement on a
modernisé notre démocratie isabelle en
est une experte une spécialiste ap non
mais c'est vrai et donc je pense que ça
sera ça sera l'occasion de le voir
geneviève je suis sûr que tu verras
beaucoup plus loin sur le s et nuit je
sais que ça ne tient à coeur et sur
l'importance évidemment de l'engagement
de tous est de 7,2 semoun de ce héros le
modèle mais si on revient en une minute
sur l'éducation à la citoyenneté et au
civisme on est tous d'accord l'éducation
morale et civique aujourd'hui n'est plus
à la hauteur des enjeux de notre temps
comme on a neuf jeunes sur dix qui ne se
déplace pas aux élections régionales ça
ne veut pas dire que c'est une jeunesse
d engager une jeunesse qui s'en fichent
une jeunesse keane qui n'est pas
politique pas du tout elle est
absolument politique elle est moins
partisane c'est vrai mais les politiques
parce que il une sorte de paradoxe mois
les jeunes que je rencontre
au delà même de nos partis il s'engage
pour des causes on a parlé des ouigours
pour les inégalités dans le monde c'est
en est un exemple pour les inégalités
sur nos territoires des jeunes ruraux
qui créent des solidarités des jeunes
qui refusent les discriminations
qu'elles soient qu'elle soit homophobe
un antisémite
qu'elle soit sur des inégalités de
traitement entre les femmes et les
hommes je vois des jeunes qui sont pro
démocratie et qui vont embarquer
d'autres jeunes en faisant des
simulations parlementaire franchement il
y en a pas un qui te dis ah ben je m'en
fiche royalement de tout ce n'est pas
mon problème par contre en parallèle ils
te disent à quoi ça sert de voter est ce
que c'est vraiment utile et finalement
votre truc c'est pas de la chicanerie
entre entre personnes est-ce que c'est
pas des histoires d'ego et là on a un
enjeu moi je pense que notre enjeu c'est
de réconcilier la force de l'engagement
du quotidien pour une cause dans une
association dans sur son territoire et
l'expression démocratique et le vote est
donc finalement revenir à quelque chose
d'assez fort c'est quand je conjugue et
démocratie directe et la démocratie
d'engagement qui celui sur nos
territoires et pour sa 2 en jeu je vois
que le temps file et et ça passe super
vite mais deux enjeux l'éducation
civique et morale bien sûr le retour
très fort de l'éducation populaire et ça
on est en train de le faire mais avec
une éducation populaire qui serait
attaque au grand enjeu de citoyenneté
quand on fait avec jean michel blanquer
vacances apprenantes quand les
parlementaires votent un budget
exceptionnel pour permettre à des jeunes
à des enfants à des adolescents de
partir en vacances mais en même temps
pendant ces vacances de comprendre nos
institutions de faire des simulations de
vote de finalement vivre la démocratie
de vivre la république est-ce que c'est
pas ça le chemin de la citoyenneté alors
même qu'on a des familles qui désertent
les sociologues les experts expliquent
que si tu n'as pas voté trois fois
d'affilée il ya de grandes chances que
tu te sentes éloignés alors on parle de
précarité citoyenne de précarité
démocratique et ça il ya des réponses et
des réponses dans nos institutions a
transformé mais cet accompagnement et
commence au plus jeune âge il commence à
l'école et dès le cp en réalité et je
crois qu'il faut arrêter d'avoir peur de
parler des grands courants de la vie
politique de notre pays alors oui il
faut des noms il faut des débats il faut
des mouvements politiques jeune plus
fort encore moi j'ai grandi dans un
mouvement politique jeunes je crois que
c'est absolument essentiel je crois et
j'espère un retour également du
syndicalisme étudiant plus constructif
plus - pour le coup politisés mais plus
fort sur l'action la proposition
aujourd'hui qu'il est qu'ils portent
dire la vie étudiante je crois que c'est
l'illustration d'une démocratie saine et
c'est en accompagnant l'éducation
populaire l'éducation civique et morale
des projets comme un service civique
européen qui ouvre en réalité les
frontières qui casse les inégalités de
destin parce qu'il permet à des jeunes
qui ne sont pas en études supérieures de
se dire l'europe c'est pour moi aussi et
donc oui quand je vote pour les
élections européennes je vote pour une
partie de mon destin et même je vais
aller plus loin quand on embarque avec
nous plus cette année au minimum ce que
nous sommes sous le président elles sont
fortes mais au minimum cinquante mille
jeunes qui ne se seraient jamais croisé
jamais parce qu'ils viennent de familles
différentes de familles monoparentales
de famille de première deuxième ou
troisième génération d'immigration des
quartiers populaires des zones rurales
mais aussi des quartiers très bourgeois
des centres villes qui vont partager
ensemble un bout en bout de vie de
france ils vont lever un drapeau ils
vont voter ils vont débattre le soir ils
vont pousser leur esprit critique
apprendra finalement écouté l'autre se
rendent compte que des fois les
difficultés parfois les difficultés d'un
jeune rurales sont les mêmes qu un jeune
de quartier parce que c'est la question
de la mobilité parce qu'ils n'ont pas
accès aux pour le coup au logement et
que finalement comment on embarque tout
ça comment répondre à tout ça en
s'engageant en allant voter en
s'engageant dans une asso il se bat
parce qu'on s'engage dans une asso qu'on
va pas voter au contraire ça démultiplie
cette puissance mais ça il faut le
redire fowler monter il faut leur
prouver parce qu'en plus on a une
génération qui est touchée par la
défiance les mots aujourd'hui ils ont
besoin de preuves c'est pour ça qu'au
gouvernement les actions l'épreuve c'est
le service des scènes vercel jamais on a
mis autant de millions parce que notre
jeunesse est notre avenir et quand je
dis ça c'est pas un slogan c'est vrai et
c'est pour ça qu'un désengagement et je
m'arrête là moi que j'ai pris mes avec
l'accord du président de la république
et pour le coup ça a été une proposition
qui a été porté et parlait jamais parlé
jdem donc je pense qu'il faut redonner
la paternité des projets pendant la paix
fut et c'est le fruit des travaux des
deux pendant la pf lieu je se fera et la
france fera les premiers réunions des
conseils des ministres emprisonne en
présence des jeunes eux-mêmes ou quand
je réunirai j'aurais plaisir l'honneur
la responsabilité en tout cas de
présider ces conseils des ministres de
la jeunesse les jeunes seront présents
et c'est ainsi sur ans elles seront plus
fermé parce que plus que jamais je pense
qu'il faut les ouvrir et si on les ouvre
alors on recrée de la confiance
merci beaucoup ça va pour cette
proposition concrète et puis et puis ta
réaction effectivement à tout ce qui
avait été dit précédemment alors je vais
maintenant passer la parole à isabelle
qui a beaucoup planché sur effectivement
les les les enjeux de participation
démocratique et tu fais partie d'un
think tank qui travaillent sur ce sujet
tu es membre aussi de commission alors
peut-être d'abord une première réaction
au débat et on était côte à côte toutes
les deux et on partage est vraiment un
enthousiasme enfin le même en se disant
vraiment effectivement
ce que j'aurais pu dire en introduction
aussi c'est que au mouvement démocrate
le pluralisme c'est vraiment dans notre
adn et on veut faire vivre ce pluralisme
et là c'était un exemple concret de
notre attachement au pluralisme alors
peut-être isabelle du coup une réaction
une réaction d'abord remercier auguste
et pour avoir eu la bonne idée de faire
une table ronde transpartisane parce que
je crois que tout le monde l'a souligné
ça permet un espace de débat et pour le
coup donné cette tribune et permettre
comme tu l'as fait un débat apaisé sur
ces questions jeunesse quand même est
une belle réussite et moi j'ai constaté
beaucoup d'idées beaucoup de talent et
ça quand même même si vous êtes déjà des
personnalités présentes aguerris aux
débats aux médias il faut le faire il
faut dire il faut savoir présenter et ça
c'est indispensable dans lequel dans le
monde dans lequel on vit maintenant donc
ça donne de l'espoir et nous ça nous
donne de l'espoir de la relève derrière
politique donc ça c'est quand même très
enthousiasmant et merci encore pour pour
ce c'était ces échanges vraiment
passionnant alors - comme tu l'as dit
alice
alors alice lui a dit alors et puis
sarah moi j'ai effectivement donc je
suis membre actuellement d'une mission
qui travaillent sur la question de
l'abstention qui a été souhaitée et mis
en place par richard ferrand
et bon passionnante évidemment nés après
ces élections départementales et
régionales et en même temps
parallèlement à ça depuis huit mois
maintenant je travaille avec plusieurs
députés de la majorité dont gilles oddly
gilles legendre qui est l'instigateur on
va dire de ce défi démocratique qui est
un groupe de réflexion et nous avançons
et notre souhait est d'avancer sur des
produits de propositions concrètes que
nous mettrons en débat je l'espère très
prochainement pour notre campagne est
notre future campagne présidentielle
et donc les deux finalement les deux
sujets se rejoignent dans cette mission
abstention et ça je voudrais vous en
parlez vous faire une proposition assez
rapidement je peux vous dire qu'il ya du
boulot d'abord parce que
on auditionne des tas de personnes et
encore la semaine dernière j'étais dans
une audition avec erwan
assez voilà qui m'a un peu voilà gêné
parce que des professeurs de droit
public vous savez ce que c'est vous êtes
opposé peut-être passer par des études
vous connaissez et ben ont été
auditionnés sur les nouvelles formes de
vote et les nouveaux modes de scrutin je
peux vous dire j'ai pris la parole parce
qu'il ya un moment ce que j'entendais me
dis que si on écoute que ces personnes
qui ont été auditionnées on produira pas
grand chose dans notre rapport final
parce qu'il faut rien changer parce que
si vous écoutez des preuves de droit
public et des profs de droit
constitutionnel je vous parle des
grandes universités un je vous parle de
lille je vous parle de la sorbonne bah
voilà donc nous notre question au défi
démocratique s'était aussi de sortir des
idées rabâché par d'état
d'universitaires sûrement très bien il
ya des plus jeunes finalement qui font
d'autres propositions mais qu on entend
moins donc l'idée là c'est de pouvoir
avancer notamment sur ce que tu as dit
auguste sur les modalités du scrutin et
sur les formes de débat public et c'est
donc sortir des idées neuves donc on a
besoin des mouvements jeune tu l'as dit
ambroise on a besoin de cette
interactivité je suis sûr que il ya des
résonances et on a des vous avez des
appuis au sein des parlementaires et au
sein des mouvements et que moi ce que je
vais proposer au président et aux
rapporteurs qui est stéphane travert
c'est que vous vous auditionne en table
ronde comme on l'a fait tout à l'heure
qu'on vous auditionne ensemble sur ce
que vous avez proposé ça peut être
intéressant je sais pas si mon idée sera
retenu la semaine prochaine mais en tout
cas je vais en parler aux rapporteurs
parce que ce que vous avez dit pour est
un petit peu nous aider nous
parlementaires qui rame ont un peu c'est
sur ces sujets je peux vous dire ça fait
quatre ans quatre ans que je me bats sur
un sujet mais petite taille on
expérimente chez moi depuis 16 ans les
machines à voter c'est pas grand chose
il y en a à peu près une quinzaine de
villes dans les hauts de seine un
moratoire mais même sur ça on nous
impose des résistances on commence un
petit peu avancé alors je vous dis pas
ce qu'on entend encore dans ces cénacles
sur le vote électronique sur les débats
vous l'avez dit sur la participation
citoyenne sur les modalités de réforme
justement de l'espace public du débat
public il ya des vraies propositions à
faire il ya des vraies propositions à
remettre au président de la république
et chacun dans nos mouvements mais
partagée finalement au sein de ce
rassemblement que nous voulons créer je
crois que vraiment là vous avez un rôle
à jouer vous avez un rôle pour nous
appuyer sur ces sujets donc moi j'en
suis persuadé et ça me donne un peu
d'espoir parce que ce que je vous dis je
l'entends dans ses auditions et j'étais
un peu seule la semaine dernière pour
dire que je n'étais pas d'accord avec ce
qu'il disait parce que les récits sens
les réticences aux évolutions de
fonctionnement elles sont là elles sont
réelles et c'est toujours les mêmes
qu'on va chercher pour ces auditions
sont toujours les mêmes personnes donc
moi je vous dis on a besoin de vous je
vais faire cette proposition concrète en
début de semaine prochaine bien entendu
nous avons repris au sein du défi
démocratique et je le redirai déjà un
certain nombre de propositions notamment
sur les inscriptions sur les listes
électorales
on en a d'autres à faire pour les jeunes
pour les moins jeunes sur les lieux de
résidence sur les lieux de travail il ya
ya ya vraiment des idées que je sais que
vous portez donc vous redire on a besoin
de vous on a besoin de laisser la parole
aux jeunes on a besoin de dialoguer avec
vos et aux jeunes et aux jeunes femmes
aussi même si moi je le promeut dans le
département
et et elles sont là et elles sont là et
alice en est la preuve mais les autres
sont ici également donc les jeunes et
les jeunes femmes je pense qu au bus tu
en as le souci ambroise évidemment mais
à nous aussi de porter porter ce
renouvellement nécessaire de la vie
politique et de la vie publique en tout
cas merci pour ce débat tout à l'heure
et à très bientôt
merci beaucoup d'abeilles
vous avez note de la proposition dont
j'espère qu'elle pourra se transformer
parce que je pense est une idée qui fera
du bien à tout le monde si elle arrive à
se transformer alors isabelle tu
mentionné certains
axes d'amélioration pour pour faire
reculer l'abstention au dojo au
mouvement démocrate et vous le savez on
a travaillé collectivement sur des
propositions pour faire reculer
l'abstention avec 5 items faciliter
l'inscription sur les listes électorales
moderniser le vote garantir le
pluralisme éveiller l'esprit citoyen est
un sujet dont on parle pas de souvent
dans le débat public la question de la
participation des plus fragiles des
personnes en situation de handicap des
personnes il ne qu'ils ne sont pas les
traits par exemple et ça c'est aussi un
sujet qui nous qui nous tient vraiment à
coeur alors je vais maintenant passer la
parole à geneviève
quelle étoile qui est notamment en
charge du devoir de mémoire et deux
étaient aussi
et en lien étroit avec les jeunes
notamment dans le cas du sn eu comment
est-ce que tu as reçu les échanges qui
viennent de se produire avec les jeunes
et quelle est ta réaction
bien bon d'abord ils n'ont pas démenti
ce que je pensais nos jeunes sont
formidables
que j'ai toujours pensé c'est pas de la
démagogie et tous ceux qui sont qui me
connaissent bien savent que je les dis
et que je le dis en boucle et que je me
suis beaucoup entouré de jeunes pour
travailler d'ailleurs dès que j'ai pas
toujours je me suis toujours entouré de
jeunes ils vieillissent comme moi bien
sûr les un moment un moment ils ont
passé un cap pour une semaine ou
simplement chaque année on prend un nom
en tout cas en tout cas moi j'ai une
confiance
presque aveugle dans la jeunesse parce
que je pense vraiment que c'est eux que
c'est l'avenir et nous avons besoin
d'eux ils l'ont bien démontré ici
d'abord vous avez été très fort vous
êtes très doué vous êtes plus beaucoup
plus doués que moi beaucoup plus
intellectuel et vous savez très bien et
non ces énoncés vos vos idées et
franchement bravo bon moi je suis
d'abord il faut que les jeunes arrêtent
de se culpabiliser ou qu'on arrête de
les culpabiliser sur ces sujets de vote
parce que je suis désolé de constater
qu'il ya pas que les jeunes qui votent
pas et
et
jeu non seulement il n'y a pas que les
jeunes mais je trouve qu'il y a de plus
en plus de personnes qui s'éloigne du
vote alors qu'elle allait voter
peut-être pas routine peut être par
habitudes familiales ou e
et qui s'éloigne qui s'éloigne du hot
donc nous avons collectivement beaucoup
de questions à nous poser
est alors bon je vais pas refaire je
vais pas redire tout ce qui a été dit
mais on a parlé d'éducation
moi je pense qu'il ya une chose
importante l'éducation civique et morale
dont on parlait tout à l'heure c'est pas
récent
le problème le problème de son absence
ou de moins
parce que c'est c'est la génération de
nos jeunes maintenant qu'ils n'ont pas
eu
une sensibilisation et moi c'est
l'éducation familiale aussi qui donc ne
se fait pas parce qu'il n'y a pas eu une
acculturation aussi des parents de ces
jeunes en plus de l'est du cap à ce
qu'on peut pas toujours tout demander
aussi nous demande beaucoup à
l'éducation nationale il faut lui
demander beaucoup elle est là pour ça
mais il ya aussi l'éducation familiale
et quand nous voyons quand même une
jeunesse qui n'a pas eu
la culture à sion par les parents
alors je sais que les familles évolué
que nous avons baissé
dans un
dans un dans le fond
c'est une culture familiale également et
les jeunes il reproduit souvent les
cultures familial quand on a porté le
débat au bon niveau dans la famille
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas fait du vote
une obligation stupide où il fallait
aller un jour un dimanche qu'on en a
donné un sens il faut que les choses et
un sens
et bien entendu une élection notamment
une élection locale par exemple bon
c'est une élection où en fait vous vous
demandez qu'est ce que ça change pour ma
vie en définitive vous savez une
élection qu'est ce que cette personne
n'a changé pour ma vie et est ce qu'elle
va faire ce qu'elle a dit alors déjà il
faut que les pour donner envie d'aller
voter il faut que ceux qui se présente
est un est un langage franc loyal et
surtout qu'ils fassent ce qu'ils ont dit
qu'ils allaient faire sans ne le sait
qu'après et la fois d'après vous n'allez
pas voter pour eux s'ils ne l'ont pas
fait ne vous donne pas confiance dont
redonner où donner de la confiance il
faut déjà que les politiques ou les gens
qui s'investit qui veulent s'investir
qui se présente inspire de la confiance
et que ceux qui sont déjà aux manettes
et bien inspire de la confiance dans
dans la politique et dans la façon de
faire de la politique et ça il ya
beaucoup de choses à dire deuxièmement
c'est vrai
deuxièmement
il va falloir quand même qu'on emploie
des mots forts parce que mes amis moi je
pense que notre démocratie est en danger
et que ça ça dépasse le champ
personnelle de chacun et j'ai bien
entendu les jeunes et je le vois la
jeunesse est très engagé mais elle est
engagée souvent sur des causes et je
suis désolé mais les causes ça fait pas
une nation
au sens où j'entends la nation c'est à
dire que je crois qu'il va falloir que
nous nous retroussions les manches c'est
ce que j'essaie de faire moi dans mon
ministère autour des valeurs de mémoire
autour aussi des valeurs que l'armée
peut donner à une nation je crois qu'il
va falloir quand même que vous les
jeunes aussi
vous expliquer aux jeunes si les moins
jeunes ne peuvent plus le faire
que nous nous devons nous nous devons
faire nation et que si l'on vote c'est
pour notre nation c'est pour notre
démocratie est un bien précieux que nous
sommes en train de perdre tous les jours
et qui recule d'autant plus que
l'abstention sera forte donc moi il faut
mettre ça au dessus de l'intérêt
particulier au dessus d'une cause il
faut mettre ça au niveau de la nation et
ça franchement
moi je le dis de façon très j
je suis très troublé par tout ce qui se
passe actuellement je suis très troublé
par cette abstention qui n'est pas que
chez les jeunes qui gagnent y compris
les anciens
et je suis je suis très troublé parce
que nous avons une cuillère d'argent
dans la bouche
nous ne le savons pas et nous allons
bientôt ne plus la voir il sera trop
tard pour pleurer
merci beaucoup mais voilà alors j'étais
passé le temps de cette nuit c'est juste
des messages je pense qu'il y a urgence
à ce que nous vraiment nous travaillons
avec force sur ces sujets notre nation
est ce qu'on est fiers de notre nation
est ce que vous les valeurs de notre
nation sont de belles valeurs je crois
et est ce que le vote
nous sommes une démocratie nous pouvons
l'affirmer haut et fort nous voyons
assez ce que les pays non démocratiques
produisent comme effets sur le monde en
terme de danger géopolitique
actuellement ce qu'il faut aussi sortir
de nos frontières et donc vraiment nous
avons besoin de la jeunesse pour ça
parce que vous vous pouvez porter aussi
ses messages auprès des jeunes et des
jeunes voilà je n'irai pas plus loin
parce que je peux être et je pense
qu'effectivement on et merci beaucoup
geneviève je pense qu'on est on est loin
d'avoir fait le tour du sujet mais en
tout cas le le timer nous indique time
out alors par rapport à ce que est ce
que disait j'aime bien je vous invite
pour poursuivre et creuser la question à
vous emparer effectivement du livre
blanc qui avait été réalisé par le
mouvement démocrate sur les propositions
pour lutter contre l'abstention c'est
synthétique c'est c'est bien bien écrit
et vraiment c'est éclairant
la note également qui a été
effectivement fait sur par la fondation
jean jaurès sur ce sujet et qui posait
la question que reste-t-il de la
démocratie quand les électeurs boudent
les urnes offre qui fait écho à ce que
disait geneviève c'est un moment quand
même un peu grave parce que à un moment
quand on aura une démocratie sans
électeurs ça va commencer à être à être
vraiment problématique pour le pour le
modèle
et voilà donc merci en tout cas d'avoir
pris le temps de ce débat qui était
sérieux qui était qualitatif qui était
vivifiant et et bravo à tous les jeunes
qui ont participé et puis et puis
maintenant qu'on a eu un temps assez
assez sérieux et bien on va vous
proposer parce que au mouvement
démocrate on aime aussi la convivialité
de passer autant d'après qui un temps de
convivialité voilà donc merci en tout
cas à toutes et à tous et bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]